God
Somali soldiers on the front lines of
South and Central Somalia they're
carrying out a government offensive
against al-shabaab the armed group has
carried out attacks against civilians
and armies for nearly a decade and a
half the Army has made significant gains
against the group since the operation
started last year officials say this
second phase in galmaduke state in
central Somalia is decisive it is the
main stronghold of the fighters the
battle has been Fierce
there is no way in which somalis can
doubt that the government will stop the
war we are determined to fight
the president is on the front line and I
the prime minister is with you this is a
matter of life and death there is no
point of return
president Hassan Sheikh Mahmoud who has
been on the battlefield for a month is
leading 12 000 soldiers and hundreds of
plant-based militia called maosulaim
security analysts say this rare
collaboration has helped produce the
most significant territorial gains
against al-shabab in many years somebody
need to change the strategy whenever
al-shabab come to the Somali military
force they managed to run over and and
and and and reflected a heavy casualty
on the Somali soldiers whenever Somali
soldiers go forward and in offense
always faded out they never never fight
in terms of in an urban war or whatever
conventional war and that's the really
something that Somali government they
need to understand and come up with a
strategy that in line with the arshava
tactics
in Mogadishu hundreds of kilometers away
from the front line volunteers are doing
what they can to help
every day they prepare bread dates and
other dry foods for the soldiers
caused a lot of violence in Somalia
we decided to cook dry food for Somali
military forces who are at the front
lines as they walk a long road to
liberate our country from al-shabab in
Somalia they get money from somalis who
they say are optimistic for the tide
against al-shabab could be Tony
Catherine sorry Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera